[Music]
oh God didn't see you there aren't you
supposed to be leaving presents no
you're thinking of my brother Santa I'm
takings Clause takings Clause with an E
you don't know your Constitution do you
I learned about it in school public
school it gives us our rights yeah
that's public school look Constitution
doesn't give you rights your protects
the rights you have from the government
but it's not doing a great job so I got
to take your stuff my stuff fifth amend
right there read it nor shall private
property be taken for public use without
just compensation boom what's just
compensation I already gave it to you
this is just a pocket Constitution it's
not just a constitution it's just
compensation well where's new process
clause or equal protection Clause aren't
you a little old to still believe in
those huh this is the worst time of year
I mean election season's right around
the
corner